as you improve your workplace with rpa
bots
you need an easy agile and comprehensive
solution to manage your environment
track metrics and control your bots and
users
welcome to the ibm robotic process
automation control center where you can
manage the available resources
and share your scripts with other users
you can schedule bots
[Music]
or configure them for manual launching
when workloads get overwhelming you can
distribute tasks across multiple bots by
automating processes with multiple steps
across computers
it's intelligent workload management
that saves you time the rpa control
center helps you stay on top of project
progress and meet slas everything you
need to boost your business performance
it's time to help your teams take
control
build and manage bots display metrics
with interactive dashboards create
robust workload plans and much more with
ibm rpa
[Music]
you